41 ans du début de la guerre j'ai 15 ans
je termine la 8e année
et aller à des cours de formation pour les opérateurs radio à travers
six mois j'appelle
unité militaire volontaire et moi
envoyer des militaires à Tcheliabinsk
école d'aviation pour navigateurs et artilleurs
opérateurs radio, je suis déjà dans l'équipe aussi
combat
[la musique]
forcer l'avion était le ferriers
mission de combat responsable que je
réalisé pendant 2 ans
[la musique]
le commandant de savoir si les gens sont gardés
regarde attentivement le chèque mais nous
nous savons que c'est peut-être déjà Bandera
karachai près de la mitrailleuse en direction du visage
envoyé la bande entre
et il y avait 12 personnes de ce côté
et d'ici mec 10 15 ans mitrailleuse
ils sont tous allés se coucher
a de nouveau couru vers nous l'unité sur
vaincre le feu
[la musique]
à la défense de deux petites récompenses aussi
souvent bien déplacé il y a
wordenberg honneur est coup cul semi est
pour le mérite militaire
comme ils disent, ils veulent communiquer à nouveau et
envoyer recevoir des lettres de jeunes
générations
[la musique]